Thank you, thank you, that's very nice I
Saw I was in Seattle
Recently and if you ever go to see at Seattle. They have a Mount Rainier is about an hour away
It's the third biggest mountain in America
It's a good one to go to I don't know who number 1 or number 2 is
But maybe one day you'll be number one you know
Dude mountains keep growing. I don't know that's stuff that I don't know but it's a good time to see it
it doesn't have the attitude of a 1 or 2 so I
Was with a buddy and we rented a car he's driving on the way out there
I see a dead horse
I mean just laid out in someone's yard, and I've never seen that before and I was like man
I bet you don't think about that when you buy a horse I get dying like you don't fast forward that far
You know that's a huge thing dying in your yard. That's the weight of a horse you know
I mean you can't just scoot it off into the woods with your foot
Maybe like let's try to get another one before the kids come home you have to
You have to tell your wife to keep the kids away for a month. You got a Google how to move a dead horse
you got to possibly get in the horse to help you do it and that's
That's not gonna. Be easy. You know I think that's what the blinders are for cuz it's like just look ahead
Don't worry about what's going on back here? I?
Already got to get are you gonna get your friends to help you do it?
And you can't spill the beans too quick on that you know you think it's hard to get them to help you move the couch
try a dead horse I
Mean you got to lie to them
You got to just make we're getting a divorce so we hate each other. Just come over bring your truck though and
And when they pull in there
Let me tell you they're gonna see it. All right. Everybody saw it it was next to the road so
They're gonna pull into that driveway and be like man. I don't think they're gonna divorce at all I
Think we're here to move that dead horse is what I think and I I say let's let him bring it up
make you a mask, but I
Will be shocked if we don't touch that dead horse today
And look if you ever have you ever have to move a dead horse
I've clearly thought about it and
You want to be you want to be the first one to the horse?
You don't want someone else to tell you where to grab a dead horse
so you just run out there like you love it like it's the third one you've done that day and
Get to the hoofs and go ahead and start lifting and be like you guys get where you guys got to get some guys down
There and let's just get it over with so
At this point we're basically at Mount Ranier and I
Was the whole car ride is that conversation so
if
If you've never if you never been to Mount Ranier just heads up. You got to pay to go up
it's not a free Mountain someone owns it and
It's all uphill it's a nightmare so
We we get up and we park and then we're like walking up this trail and I'm going up it
I mean I can barely breathe
And this couples coming down and I like stop them
I was like hey is this like enough like where we're at like
you know is this like you get it like we're not trying to live on this mountain so
Is this like good you know and?
The lady goes I'm 75 years old, and I did it and I was like maybe that's why I didn't hear the question that I
asked the guys I
Mean everybody's pretty cocky on the way down you know like
There was women with babies they had three-month-old baby strapped to their chests
I was like why would you bring that much extra weight with you? I left my wallet in the car
They looked exhausted. I'm surprised. They're not just babies left up there and Rangers have to come down who's babies s
It's like that's our as we were let it grow up and come down on its own
It was a huge mistake bringing that baby today
So we get it we get our picture and we come back down, so now we're driving back and
Since my buddy was driving
He did not he did not see the dead horse the first time you know and I was like well
You gotta see it, dude. You can't not see it. You know that's all I've talked about so
We we get to the house, I kind of remembered where it was and we get to the house
I was like it's right here, and I pointed and the horse was standing up doing
unbelievable, I mean it was one of the healthier horses that I've ever seen and I
And then I realized you know what I guess I've never seen a horse sleep either so
Thank you guys so much
Morning Norman Shana normal nor